offenbar war es noch nicht ganz zu ende
gedacht als olaf scholz die impfpflicht
angekündigt hat ganz kurz bevor er
kanzler wurde hat er hier bei bild live
das gesagt und da hat er einen klaren
zeitplan auch relativ klaren zeitplan
angekündigt für das ja inkrafttreten der
impfpflicht
mein vorschlag ist ja dass der zeitpunkt
bis zu dem dann jeder und jede sich
haupt impfen lassen auch nicht allzu
fern liegt also mein vorschlag anfang
februar oder anfang märz herr stegner
anfang februar anfang märz jetzt ist
klar das klappt nicht der zeitplan wird
nicht zu halten sein warum
naja ich glaube es ist schon richtig
dass das in so einer frage eine
gewissensentscheidung im deutschen
bundestag ist und die abgeordnete sich
das genau überlegen können und wir
werden auch nur dicke debatte haben und
ich glaube wir können könnten das
schaffen so eine gesetzgebung im ersten
quartal hinzugekommen sie hilft ja auch
nicht unmittelbar für die situation die
wir jetzt haben sondern mittelbar in
richtung der mutmasslich nächsten welle
im herbst aber das hat er gesagt
november das hat im november/dezember
niemand gesagt nein ich bin ich konnte
dir ja auch dass die kompliziertheit der
umsetzung nicht zu vernachlässigen ist
wenn man so eine gesetzgebung macht muss
das solide sein ich bin auch bei vielen
kommt von freudenberg mit ihr einig wir
uns auch in dem punkt ist die
bürgerlichen freiheitsrechte den bürgern
gehören unterstrich zumindest sondern
man muss immer begründen weil man davon
abweicht ich würde aber sagen die
begründung ist da und die gewinnung
liegt darin das wird den
gesundheitsschutz der bevölkerung und
dass wir eben menschen die krank wären
die longo fit bekommen ist schwierigsten
konsequenzen oder die sterben müssen das
sind schon sehr viele verstorben um ihre
situation auf den intensivstationen und
das steht zu befürchten dass das weiter
so der fall ist womöglich andere melden
die an anderen schweren krankheiten
leiden nicht operiert werden kann wo die
pflegekräfte überlastet werden das heißt
es gibt gute gründe zu sagen in der
güterabwägung
musterstaat in den gesundheitsschutz zu
erreichen von einer krise wie wir sie
über uns in dieser dimension noch nie
hatten in der geschichte unserer
republik auch sagen können ich habe mich
geärgert ich hätte das mit der
helmpflicht nicht ausschließen sollen
weil wir gehofft hatten menschen
gehörten in höherem maße sich impfen
lassen wir stellen aber es war ein
fehler nicht impfen lassen extrem
gefährdet sind auch andere mittelbar
gefährden und deswegen glaube ich ist
die diskussion über lebens nicht richtig
und lieber einen monat länger brauchen
um das im parlament zu beschließen weil
man eben komplizierte dinge regeln muss
als übers knie brechen und es macht
nicht eine regierung mit eigener
mehrheit sondern ich finde
gewissensentscheidung nicht verbauen uns
überhaupt zu solchen bundesrat noch im
november dezember sagt dennoch ja das
wird februar/märz werden und das wird
noch 20 21 passieren dass der anträge
auf dem tisch lägen aus dem bundestag
das ist nicht passiert sie sind
spd-bundestagsabgeordneter der sie
hätten sich längst zusammenfinden können
mit einer gruppe von anderen spd
abgeordneten mit cdu-abgeordneten
csu-abgeordneten und das schön
ausarbeiten können warum haben sie da
ihren job ganz offenbar nicht gemacht
als spd fraktion als abgeordneter nein
so ist das nicht ich glaube es wird
jetzt unterschiedliche anträge aus
unterschiedlichen gruppen geben und noch
mal nicht nach fraktionen auch in meiner
fraktion gibt es unterschiedliche
meinung zu diesem thema und das ist auch
richtig so dass menschen
unterschiedliche meinung haben kann und
meinungsfreiheit finde ich die kann hier
nicht zur disposition stehen in dieser
frage dass der orden nicht eine
regierung aber kennt es ist eine
schwierige abwägungsfrage impulse an
unterschiedlichen konten zum 3 1
reagiert und diese an geld in der
opposition ich bin in der
regierungsfraktion und ich glaube das
mittel bei solchen fragen das über
gruppenanträge zu machen gewissen naja
aber an also häuser kennen sie einen
antrag der jetzt vorliegt also so
kompliziert es ist aber ich weiß dass
ich weiß dass an solchen anträgen
gearbeitet wird das wird demnächst auch
eingebracht werden es gibt schon einen
antrag dagegen die im verein gemeint ist
von herrn kubicki und anderen das wird
andere anträge geben ich bin sicher die
werden innerhalb der nächsten 14 tage
ein gemacht arbeitet man im moment gar
nicht wer arbeitet denn daran man weiß
dass coop eg gearbeitet hat man weiß
dass auch linda teuteberg gearbeitet hat
man weiß es von anderen abgeordneten an
diesem gegenantrag dass die daran waren
das vorgestellt haben aber wer arbeitet
konkret an dem antrag der der meinung
entspricht von olaf scholz vom
bundeskanzler zum beispiel der
abgeordnete karl lauterbach ja nicht nur
bundesgesundheitsminister ist er noch
abgeordneter des deutschen bundestages
ist er beteiligt sich zum beispiel an
der arbeit des antrags nicht höre es
gibt einen dritten an die richtung geht
eine impfpflicht ab 50 jahren
vorzuschlagen auch das ist ein antrag
der noch nicht auf den tisch legt aber
angekündigt ist es wird verschiedene
anträge geben und dann wird der
bundestag beraten in erster lesung
vermutlich noch in diesem monat und ich
denke mal anlauf des ersten quartals
wäre also macht es doch die regierung
wenn karl lauterbach das macht also die
regierung sah wohl aus dem aus dem kreis
des bundestags passieren und jetzt sagt
ralf stegner als abgeordneter nach denen
er abgeordneten in er nennt das ist karl
lauterbach also der gesundheitsminister
und das ist ein tag an dem ich das weiß
aber es gibt viele andere die jetzt
nicht möchten dass ich sie hier nenne
naja nicht richtig dass auf dem weg zu
tun aber er ist einer der beteiligten
hat er seine abgeordneten nicht
abgegeben dadurch dass der
bundesminister und wann wann soll das
vorliegen also jetzt mal über einen
realistischen zeitplan sprechen ich weiß
nicht ob sie heute bild am sonntag
gelesen haben da gab es ein großes
interview mit dem jetzt justizminister
mit marco buschmann und er sagt dort das
ja auch noch ein gewaltiger zeitraum
liegt auch wenn man jetzt ganz schnell
das machen wird zwischen inkrafttreten
des gesetzes und dann verabschieden also
zwischen verabschiedung und in kraft
treten mehrere monate das heißt das ist
gar keine sache über die wir aktuell
eigentlich reden müssen das betrifft
genau wie sie es gerade schon gesagt
habe vielleicht irgendwann man sie
zukünftige welle oder neues virus das
ist nicht so gut dass wir werden damit
nicht nur hier im frühjahr um die ecke
kommen wir schauen auch nicht vor der
sommerpause darüber
wir reden darüber dass es ende januar
vermutlich eine debatte in erster lesung
im deutschen bundestag geben wird
vielleicht ende des ersten quartals ein
gesetz verabschiedet werden kann das
dann anfang april auch im bundesrat
behandelt werden könnte darüber reden
wir schon aber zum beispiel die frage
wie man das mit oder ohne hilf register
machen da gibt es auch da gibt es auch
unterschiedliche meinungen dazu das
nötig ist ob es möglich ist es
entscheidet darüber wie kompliziert und
langwierig das ist nur ist einfach keine
unmittelbare wirkung für die situation
im januar natürlich aber dass das herbst
kommt schnell das ist nicht irgendwann
sondern er kommt ziemlich schnell und
wir wollen nicht erleben dass es wieder
so ist das im sommer eine normalisierung
der verhältnisse am und im herbst sind
wir wieder zurück in dem was wir jetzt
haben wir locker und oder andere dinge
drohen enorme schäden für jungen juli
darüber reden wir jetzt tatsächlich wir
reden über einen in kraft treten
möglicherweise im zu beginn des zweiten
quartals ich glaube dass das möglich ist